ja gut morgen also wir sind an der
grenze zu nrw wir stehen im südlichen
niedersachsen und drei kilometer in die
richtung des kameramanns ist nrw und ja
die stimmung in münster schien gut zu
sein da wurde ja auch fleißig
geschaufelt und auch hinter mir wurde
fleißig geschaut bestehen auf einem
rastplatz an der a 30
ja und da müssen die lkw fahrer
tatsächlich mit sehr profanen mittel mit
dachlatten und mit pappkartons ihre ihre
lkw freischaufeln obwohl hier ja ein
fahrverbot besteht gegeben ich gehe mal
ein bisschen zur seite der festung kann
mal ein mal hier auf die strassen und
auf die auf die autobahn zoomen
wir sehen auf der rechten seite stehen
ganz ganz viele lkw und hier auf der
linken seite auch weil die können nicht
weiterfahren weil sie festgefroren sind
und b dürfen sie eigentlich auch gar
nicht weiterfahren weil nämlich hier ein
fahrverbot bis 12 uhr besteht und auch
in den regierungsbezirken in owl und im
münsterland aber da muss man auch sagen
dass da ganz viele der lkw fahrer
überhaupt nichts von mitbekommen haben
teilweise sprechen die auch nicht die
sprache in der das kommuniziert wurde
und als wir hier hingefahren sind heute
morgen ganz ganz früh muss man sagen
dass auch die lkw fahrer wirklich
richtig kacheln auf der autobahn die
straßenverhältnisse sind wirklich sehr
sehr sehr sehr schwierig das was frank
gerade aus münster berichtet hat hier
schneidet die ganze nacht tatsächlich
durch es wird immer kälter wir haben
jetzt schon gefühlt nehmen nicht gefühlt
wir haben gemessen gerade das waren -
zehn bis elf grad da war das temperatur
messgerät nicht ganz so richtig in
schuss allerdings sind hier im landkreis
osnabrück die schulen ausgefahren der
nahverkehr ist ist dicht die busse
fahren nicht wir haben gerade
mitbekommen dass auch rettungskräfte die
auf einsätze gerufen werden von der
freiwilligen feuerwehr begleitet werden
müssen damit die wagen nicht einfrieren
wir gehen jetzt noch einmal an die seite
wir sehen nämlich da auf der rechten
seite ist gerade einen lkw gekommen
der jetzt so ein bisschen lkw ballett
macht na also vorwärts ging es nicht und
jetzt wird das sehr wahrscheinlich
gleich ganz zurücksetzen und die
einfahrt
des parkplatzes als ausfahrt nutzen das
haben wir auf jeden fall gerade schon
mehrfach gesehen also es ist teilweise
wirklich auch mit welchen mitteln man
hier versucht dann doch noch
weiterzukommen schon ich sag mal sehr
grenzwertig wir haben gerade auch mit
einem lkw fahrer gesprochen er sagte was
auf kollege ich habe gerade echt ganz
ganz andere sorgen als jetzt so erklären
was ich für probleme habe
du siehst es ja ich komme nicht weiter
ich habe ware geladen ich habe wichtige
ware geladen und ich muss einfach von a
nach b
natürlich wird es für die logistiker
heute ein problem werden zum beispiel
wenn es mit tanks die müssen halt von a
nach b gefahren werden weil die
landwirte haben zum beispiel auch nicht
endlos kapazitäten in ihren ställen und
ihre nieren kühlfächer da jetzt einfach
vielleicht eng werden die
straßenmeisterei ist die ganze zeit im
volleinsatz polizei muss ich sagen habe
ich wirklich überhaupt noch nicht
gesehen in den städten wo wir heute
morgen losgefahren sind türmt sich der
schnee ungefähr zwei bis drei meter in
den einfahrten die leute laufen nicht
auf dem gehweg weil man dann nämlich
versinken würde die laufen dann auf den
straßen
also ich glaube dass wir mit dieser
wetterlage hier noch einige tage zu tun
haben werden wir nicht ehrlich gesagt
osnabrück und nahezu zum erliegen die
lkw fahrer könne nicht weiter dass hier
mit einigen auf gesprochenes wie geht es
jetzt für die weitersehen wichtige waren
geladen müssen eigentlich weiter heißt
es jetzt einfach standheizung anderen
auf dem parkplatz ausharren
man kann ja auch nirgendwo
zusammensitzen in corona zeiten und
meinen waren t irgendwo drin genießen
sie fassen die männer das jetzt vor ort
auf also so ein trucker ansicht der
islam war erfinderisch
die haben halt alles an bord was was
auch so eine kleine einliegerwohnung mit
sich bringt mikrowelle tv-gerät die
haben genügend batterien also ist ja
nicht so dass die dass die ständig
durchfahren die stehen ja auch des
öfteren in meinem stau die können darin
kochen das ist alles fein aber natürlich
der austausch mit den kollegen
betrifft jetzt gerade einfach nur wie
man am besten seinen wagen freischaufeln
der haben gerade tatsächlich ein gesehen
ja mit kochsalz versucht hat also mit
normalen mit normalem sei ein bisschen
schnee pro von seinen reifen zu befreien
um dann sein gespann wieder schlüssig zu
bekommen das ist natürlich sehr
schwierig man kann natürlich die
sanitären einrichtungen benutzen die
sich an den raststätten bieten wir sind
ja nicht zu aber die verhandeln
natürlich alle mit ihren chefs wir haben
gerade versucht natürlich auch mal raus
zu bekommen wie es dann weitergeht und
der mann sagt ganz ehrlich ich habe
überhaupt keine ahnung bei viele wissen
einfach auch nichts von diesem
fahrverbot und es wird dann auch nicht
in den sprachen übermittelt
in denen die brummifahrer hier teilweise
sprechen sehr sehr viele osteuropäer
sind gerade hier unterwegs aber selbst
hier auf dem rastplatz herrscht so ein
bisschen ja ahnungslosigkeit und wir
sind auch tatsächlich überrascht dass
hier keiner ist der die der immer
irgendwie nachfragt wie es denn geht
hier werden keine warmen getränke
gereicht dass das hier das hier tee
ausgeschenkt wird oder so das kann aber
auch eventuell noch kommen weil die lage
wie ich ja gerade schon erwähnt habe
wird sich jetzt nicht über kurz oder
lang ändern wir gehen davon aus dass es
hier wirklich den ganzen tag noch weiter
durchschneiden wird und auch in der
woche hier nicht viel an fernverkehr
fließen wird
also ich stehe bei groß schönebeck in
sachsen-anhalt
sie haben hier übernachtet auf dem
platz und sind aufgebracht was ist da
los realisieren kein wieder okay
das heißt sie sind daraus machen ist
schon raus bringen weil der mit zu laut
ist sie sind aufgebracht
der parkplatz war und wer hat schuld an
der misere
ich habe keine ahnung bratschen aber ich
habe keinen winterdienst gesehen hier
ok also die lastwagenfahrer an da hilft
sind komplett eingeschneit sie kriegen
die sattelschlepper nicht mehr gerade
gezogen
der ganze parkplatz ist voll kamera
kollegen von usern von jetzt versucht
die schneeketten anzulegen um den
grossen bouquet freizukriegen er muss
abliefern heute heute haben sich heute
ja wer es aus köln gekommen hat
vorschriftsmäßig die ruhezeit
eingehalten hat hier übernachtet habe
auch niemand zu gefährden vorbildlich
und ist ausgemacht der ganze park platz
22 30 die winter voll stehe unter dem
schnee war eine spiegelglatte fläche
josef wie geht es jetzt weiter wie
machen sie weiter wie erwartet wir
kommen nicht raus und hier ja keine
andere wahl
hier muss man haben
also zum glück ist josef nicht in gefahr
mit seinen kollegen aber seine ware wird
ja heute nicht seine ladung oder nicht
fristgerecht abliefern können aber es
ist nicht seine schuld
es ist eben doch dass sie überall die
auch an der a 11 ich bin ganz gut
durchgekommen ich war heute von der hat
keine krone die straße an sich die
autobahn war frei aber hier unten die
rastplätze
das ist wirklich der hat niemand heute
geräumt und die laster kommen natürlich
da nicht raus so ist die situation hier
an der a 14
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren